a lot of major developments coming out
of today's hearing on Capitol Hill about
the biggest national security threats
facing our country the Director of
National Intelligence is issuing this
disturbing alarm frankly the United
States is under attack under attack by
entities that are using cyber to
penetrate virtually every major action
that takes place in the United States
from US businesses to the federal
government to state and local
governments the United States is
threatened by cyber attacks every day
director Coates also warns Russia might
already be trying to meddle in this
year's midterms we expect Russia to
continue using propaganda social media
false flag personas sympathetic
spokesmen and other means to influence
to try to build on its wide range of
operations and is a sir bait social and
political fissures in the United States
there should be no doubt that Russia
perceived that its past efforts as as
successful and views the 2018 US midterm
elections as a potential target for
Russian influence operations all right
Dana so this has been sort of in in the
works and in the pipeline people talking
about it what kind of national security
threat ongoing national security threat
that the Russians posed and now
specifically looking at a target of the
midterm elections in the United States
well that and yes so this hearing was
super interesting it was about all these
different threats there's a lot of them
but this was the one that really got
some attention because we've we've been
talking about this for a long time and
Democrats really want to relitigate 2016
and there is not evidence that there was
Russian meddling like in the actual
machines that change the votes but I
don't think there's anyone that's
questions still questioning whether or
not they tried to influence through
these other means as social actors just
mentioned and the false flags and it's
clear that the government hasn't done
enough to try to figure out what we are
going to do going forward and so part of
it is that Americans are just going to
have to be smart about the information
that they consume and that's that's okay
in a democracy we can trust the voters
to do
but in the meantime it's the other
threats that are also a problem Bill
Gates also today issued his annual
letter to Microsoft employees in which
he said something that Gregg has said
for many years which is that if you
marry up there's pretty easy technology
with biological agents that you could
then put on a drone and you send it into
the city all of these things are
emerging and you don't have to be a
superpower in order to wage war now you
convince somebody just one person in
your basement yeah you're working on it
okay Greg
you're a failure with one person in your
basement yeah that is me or Lou Dobbs
depending on what day of the week it is
you took everything I was going to say I
I want to make two points to the top
security threat is technology married to
terror
you don't need 10,000 jihadists anymore
you just need one with know-how it's not
like a nation-state which has everything
to lose an individual who wants to die
will take all of you with you because
they have nothing to lose North Korean
Russia you could call them enemies but
they still want to survive because their
goals are on the globe jihadists goals
are in heaven so we are biggest our
biggest fear or danger is our own
complacency we have to look at the
jihadist threat forever
it's not some geopolitical force this is
a toxic ideology and we have to deal
with it
about the cyber security cyber terror
thing we have to be careful when we keep
saying we're under attack
obviously Russians are gonna spy North
Koreans are gonna spy the Chinese are
gonna spy we're gonna spy everybody
spies we always look at spying as
somehow a defensive tool like we're
going to get information we're going to
get information about Russia or the USSR
way back when and then for that that's
how we create our defenses the problem
with hacking is when you say somebody
hacks like North Korea hacks Russia
hacked we think of it as a nation we
don't think it's a nation attacking us
I think that's a bit dangerous I think
we have to look at this the way we
looked at normal spying hacking is just
an adaptation of that spine it's not a
nation on an offensive it's perhaps a
spy on a defensive thing still bad but
it's something that we have to put into
perspective so we don't mistake a
defensive action as an offensive one and
launch a war do something that's my
that's my theory that I stolen from
somebody else okay when you want to get
back to us with the attribution
please but I can't remember who it was
but if somebody smarter than me hmm
that's everyone okay Jessie I think the
Russian cyber threat is real but at the
same time let's put it into perspective
the Russians spent $100,000 on Facebook
ads last election Hillary Clinton spent
tens of millions of dollars on Facebook
at her whole campaign spent 1.1 billion
dollars in advertising when you look at
outside groups 1.4 billion in
advertising when you add the mainstream
media propaganda to that combine that
with Hillary there is much more anti
Trump propaganda than there was Pro
Trump propaganda in the election so and
purchased influence and Israel the
biggest influence I believe of Russia
propaganda in the last election was the
dossier paid for by Hillary Clinton it
infected the bloodstream of the US
government and now look what we're
talking about still a year later also
the DNC claims they were hacked by the
Russians yet they never handed over
their server how seriously do they
actually take it Podesta says he was
hacked by the Russians he ended up
giving them his password which was
password President Obama admitted that
he was worried about Russian
interference in the election and never
said anything about it actually feels
guilty
so I'm friends with the guy that runs
the Harvard cyber security team and he
just briefed Congress the other day and
he said this it's like crime
you're never gonna fully prevent it
you're gonna have to realize some of
it's going to happen but when Russia
comes to mess with us
we have to hit them back hard so they
pay a price all right well good I hope
he's helping you with cyber security
okay one swivel for me I'm just stunned
because I six to me like people are
putting on blinders so they don't have
to say Russia influence the 2016
election and we should know the details
of it so we can prevent a recurrence in
the future and what we heard today was
that this is an ongoing assault that is
an offensive assault recently in the
course of the budget shutdown there was
a hashtag called Schumer shut down
trending and it you know got lots of
attention and amplified them by
mainstream media and Democratic
politicians who in the midst of
here effort to say we're gonna blame
this on the Republicans and hey boy
look at how social media's play later it
comes out the polls supported the
Democrats but the Russians the bots and
all their propaganda efforts were
pushing hashtag Schumer shut down just
point one I let you speak man so this
goes on every day these days on every
political issue in America where public
opinion is influenced to the benefit of
the Russians and we cannot sit silent as
Americans say well you know it could be
that this country of that country
according to our top and tells us
officials testifying today it's Russia
it's Iran it's China and if we want to
protect our democracy our basic our
fundamentals we got to get serious all
right can I respond to that one second
this is this issue is damaging in that
it thrives on team sport politics for
Russia it's about disrupting our
foundation and the way it disrupts our
foundation is by splitting us so we're
expending all this energy coring
quarreling over who did the Russians
help who did the Russians hurt it's
exactly what a global prankster what so
the solution to this we have to step
back and say there there aren't two
oppositional sides on this both sides
just at one and myself we should
relinquish a bit of this tribal turf and
say that okay you could you can agree
there is Russian interference I know
there is and there always will be it
yeah the other thing but then you have
to say there might not be evidence that
there was another side to it that the
Trump's didn't do anything however I'm
okay I'm open to the whole investigation
don't get what I'm saying to you is
there can be no debate about what took
place we get it everyone knows and
according to the US intelligence
community and their reports are Russia
and China are the most sophisticated in
terms of the nation-state actors